us know that the Universe really doesn't
give a [ __ ] about you it is not sending
you messages
I think you can find messages within the
nonsense from the universe
there are it's not all random here we
are not all it's not all completely
random
if you would have said to me in 1997
Dave you're going to be sitting with
Bill Maher at his house he's going to be
smoking pot Chevy Chase was just there
before blah blah blah you'd be married
to a dude Bill Maher would be talking to
you about anal sex like that is so
[ __ ] bananas my head would have
exploded
foreign
people it is October 10 2022 I'm Dave
Rubin this is the Reuben report we are
live streaming on rumbleblaze TV and
YouTube subscribe if you have not and
yes
the conversation the long-awaited chat
over tequila and later on marijuana with
Bill Maher is up right now my two plus
hour uh chat with Bill at Club random
which is a club that he has at his house
it's a separate structure uh it is up
right now we're going to show you a
bunch of Clips throughout the show today
we sort of uh we framed the show today
around the conversation that I had with
Bill the conversation was about a week
and a half ago they held it for a little
bit but they did to their credit and I
was a little concerned about this uh to
the credit of bill and his producers and
everyone over there they did not edit
one second of the thing it's the longest
conversation that bill has had on the
podcast a little over two hours we
actually could have gone way longer in
many ways and I'm seeing a lot of
comments uh from you guys on this by the
end at the two hour mark basically we
were sort of just getting going because
it took a little while
to kind of feel each other out and all
of that stuff we had never met we had
met before like quick hellos and I took
a picture with them once but we had
never actually sort of met before as as
sort of full equal human beings and it
was just getting going and they kept uh
there was a little clock next to the uh
little area where we were sitting and I
saw they kept adding time to it which
obviously meant they were they were
pleased how the conversation was gone
unfortunately I had to get going because
I had to get on the red eye because I
was heading to New York uh to ring the
bell for rumble I guess not
unfortunately but I did have to get
going uh in any event we are going to
frame Today's Show around that
conversation and sort of the Divide
between say uh the the old school
liberal and what I would say is a new
school conservative and really with the
The Wider uh that will all sort of fit
into a bucket of uh I think there's ways
to have these conversations and Bill and
I just took a first stab at it but
before I tell you anything else about
that there's a lot of good stuff Trust
there's a lot of good stuff I asked him
if he'd moved to Florida I asked him if
he'd vote for DeSantis we did as much of
it as we could I should tell you uh I
had another child we had a baby number
two arrived on what was that Thursday uh
hence why I didn't have a show on Friday
and I'm very excited to tell you that he
is healthy and happy and that Justin
baby one has a new baby brother just two
months to the day Justin was born on
August 6th and baby two was born on
October 6. his name is Luke and uh we
are thrilled he is happy and healthy and
the pediatrician was here yesterday and
it's all good and I'm waking up now
instead of Twitter with two babies on me
and there's milk everywhere and all it's
nuts and it's all good life is good I'm
feeling very good about things I do have
to address one thing though because a
lot of people are asking me this friends
family and I'm sure I'm going to see
comments about it where do you come up
with the name Luke is this about Star
Wars obviously is this about Star Wars
now the issue is that years ago I've
always liked the name Luke I'm surprised
there aren't more Luke's out there you
would have thought with Luke Skywalker
and and Star Wars you would have thought
that every third person you would meet
would be named Luke but David and I
agreed we both like the name Luke and
even years ago when we first started
talking about kids Luke was sort of in
the running we always knew Justin was
going to be number one but Luke was in
the running and then unfortunately the
last couple Star Wars were absolutely
horrible they completely trashed Luke's
character and Mark Hamill the actor who
plays Luke Skywalker he is a leftist
lunatic I think maybe he called me
racist once on Twitter it just ruined
Star Wars for me it ruined Luke and all
that but we still like the name but I
knew if we named the kid Luke he's every
day of his life they're good oh Luke
like in like Luke Skywalker Star Wars
okay and I was like I can't live with
that I can't do that to this kid so I
like I was like we've got to find
another
to have any of this make sense and then
it hit me in the most beautiful way
possible this was about two months ago
when we were finalizing the name you may
remember the final episode of The Golden
Girls it was a two-part episode called
one who left the Cuckoo's Nest or flew
out of the Cuckoo's Nest something like
that and Dorothy played by uh B Arthur
she gets married to blanche's Uncle
Uncle Lucas played by Leslie Nielsen I
think we've got a picture from the
wedding right there
so ladies and gentlemen my Luke is named
after Uncle Lucas played by one of the
great comic actors of all time Leslie
Nielsen Naked Gun to me the funniest
movie of all time he married Bea Arthur
who's one of the greatest comedic
actresses of all time so it is not in
honor of Luke Skywalker I just want to
be clear about that it could have been
but Mark Hamill and Kathleen Kennedy and
Disney ruined Star Wars I wanted to keep
the name Luke Uncle Lucas Luke there you
go little sidebar had to get it out let
me talk to you real quick about Rex MD
then we're going to get into Bill Maher
and everything else going on into in the
world and I assure you ladles and jelly
spoons there's a lot guys I hate going
to the doctor everyone does it literally
takes a half a day to get it done and
you don't want to talk to your doctor
about certain things here's the thing
most men's health issues have really
Simple Solutions Rex MD is about Simple
Solutions Rex MD makes getting generic
and branded Viagra or Cialis easy
everything's online even the
prescription and they deliver to your
door no office visits no talking to a
receptionist super simple did you know
that Viagra can cost around 90 bucks a
pill jeez but Rex MD has generic Viagra
for as low as two dollars a pill just
fill out a quick medical questionnaire
on their website a doctor will review
your situation and prescribe you generic
Viagra if appropriate your medication
gets shipped right to your door
with free two-day shipping it's fast
simple and cheap and you can access your
U.S licensed Rex MD physician anytime
you need Rex MD has helped over 300 000
guys get generic Viagra quickly and
conveniently Rex MD just works and it
works the very first night starter packs
of generic Viagra Cialis are now
available for our viewers go to
rexmd.com Ruben to get started that's
rexmd.com Ruben go to rexmd.com Ruben
today to get a starter packed
prescription of generic Viagra or Cialis
all orders come with free two-day
shipping and you'll probably have a
great rest of your afternoon I would
imagine okay now let's get to it so I
was on Bill Maher's podcast Club random
which he just launched over the last
couple months I've been going back and
forth with the producers there for quite
some time I honestly did not think
because they reached out to me
originally about eight months ago and it
got delayed a couple times I really
didn't think it was going to happen I
really didn't you guys know I don't have
to belabor the point about how bill has
influenced me and yet we've sort of had
our fork in the the road moment but if
guys like us can't sit down and and talk
it out and agree that we want to live in
the same country and maybe agree to
disagree on some issues then America has
no hope that's why I was so looking
forward to this conversation uh I think
we got an image I think we showed that
to you a couple days ago that was after
about two and a half hours and a lot of
tequila and yes I did uh smoke the
marijuana I said I wasn't going to or I
thought I wasn't going to at the
beginning but about an hour and a half
in we were just having a ball and I was
like let's just do it and it was just
it was just great okay so uh let me show
you one clip up top here that's going to
sort of set up the show today and that's
about what I just mentioned that you
know all of us evolve politically in
certain ways some people get stagnated
some people change some people go
towards truth and that it's our job to
kind of figure it out for ourselves and
and see where we end up here's me and
Bill I like Larry I mean he says some
goofy conservative [ __ ] but so do you
that may well and that's okay yeah that
may well be
um and some people think I do it most of
the people who love me love all of your
crazy concern that's a I mean that's a
Nutty one for you right but I'm not
conservative I'm just I'm just
appropriately critical of the excesses
of the left which are plenty these days
well sane I think it could be sane
because when people say to me oh Bill
Maher is getting red pilled or something
and I talk about you a lot on my show
because you've been a huge huge
influence on me if I talk about you a
lot on the show and then people ask well
wait a minute you know you and Bill used
to sort of see eye to eye on all of this
stuff and then I kind of shifted a
little bit and then they'll say to me
Bills Bill's sane and I go well well
liberals were supposed to be saying yeah
I must say yeah yeah but that's got to
be weird watching everybody go nuts I
mean I watch sure I'll go nuts and I
watch them all or not and shifting is
okay
because things change so sometimes we
have to change you know you know and
sometimes we grow we learn take in new
material
okay so that really was the theme of the
episode and we we talked about all sorts
of stuff I mean we basically talked
about the meaning of life he asked me a
lot of sex questions which I wasn't
thrilled about
um but we we talked about and then we
dipped in and out of politics you know
the producers were clear uh with me from
the beginning that the show couldn't be
all politics I know a certain set of
people wanted me to just go in there and
bludgeon him and why did you say that
you wanted the economy to crash under
Trump and this and that the other thing
but what I really really wanted to do
more than anything else was make that
human connection and then and then
hopefully this is just the beginning of
well he'll come on this show he invited
me to go back on real time or go on real
time for the first time and that we can
have this further conversation it wasn't
about walking in there and just punching
the guy in the face I'm also in his home
uh you know so so that was really I
think a nice way to to set up what we're
doing here today we change and all of
those things by the way the the Larry
that he's referencing up top I had
mentioned something about Larry Elder so
that's the Larry he was mentioning up
top anyway we got got into Florida and
California and people making choices for
themselves and guys like me leaving
Florida are leaving for Florida from
California Freedom you know freedom and
that's it that's why I fled this place
right away right LED Cali this year I
couldn't take it anymore is that right
yeah I lived in La for the last eight
years I left on December 17 2021. we're
down back for one day I honestly I where
did you get this place I'm in Florida
I'm in free Florida man oh
no I I get it about Florida I've talked
about Florida a lot I it's a love-hate
relationship but so is my relationship
with California yeah but I ain't going
who am I kidding I mean it's just I'm
too dug in and my friends are here and
my studio is here and there's still some
great things about California
so it's interesting because I'm telling
him all the reasons I left and he agrees
with a lot of those Reasons by the way
we're going to show you a clip a little
bit later where I get him directly to
talk about what could cause him to go to
Florida to actually get out of
California and it does have a little
something to do with kovid and that Ron
DeSantis guy but it's interesting
because you know a certain type of
person you know you're dug in in a
certain way you're of a certain age you
have your friends all those things and
you have the the finances to maybe stay
and see what happens and then other
people just want to get out this is this
is the point everyone negotiates in
their own life oh I have young kids I
better get out now before they're more
entrenched or I have young kids and
that's why I have to stay because their
grandparents live here or all of those
things he goes a little more into his
love hate thing with uh with Florida and
it's funny because the the negatives on
Florida uh for him seem to have to do
with with the partying in Miami but I
I'm here in Miami guys were you guys
partying a lot this weekend no very
boring people it's it's you know
you go out you have dinner you lay at
the beach it's all it's all good here
um anyway we'll see if we can get him to
Florida but that gives me a good sort of
segue uh to what's going on right here
in Florida because as you know we stayed
open I say we I wasn't even here for the
beginning of it Florida managed to stay
open throughout covid because we had not
only Governor DeSantis but incredible
people around him who were actually
looking at the science not pretending
that they were the science uh this
weekend uh a tweet by Florida Surgeon
General Dr Joseph latipo about the MRNA
vaccines was deleted I want to show you
the original tweet or this is from
Disclose TV this is when the Tweet got
deleted just in Twitter has removed a
tweet from Florida Surgeon General Dr
Joseph latipo about mRNA vaccines for
violating the platform's rules now
what's fascinating about this we have
the Tweet right I think we've got the
Tweet today we released an analysis on
covid-19 mRNA vaccines the public needs
to be aware of this now analysis showed
an increased risk of cardiac related
death among men 18 to 39 Florida will
not be silent on the truth and then he
links to the study so this is our
Surgeon General here in Florida they did
a study the study finds that there's
cardiac issues amongst young men who
take this vaccine Twitter takes it down
okay Twitter takes it down and then what
happens well the usual thing happens
because they haven't banned and silenced
everyone yet there's a huge pushback and
then Twitter did actually bring the
Tweet back
now it's interesting because a lot of
people see that as a win and at that
very sort of uh base level uh it is a
win okay there they deleted something
and they brought it back now the real
question though of course is did they
then suppress the views it was
originally supposed to be out it was
gone for like 24 hours do they Shadow
ban it et cetera Etc this is why Elon
Musk has a [ __ ] ton of work as a
technical term to do once he gets
Twitter to find out all of the things
they have been doing to us endlessly and
by the way when I say endlessly it
continues uh because Dr Anthony fauci
the man who claims that if you criticize
him you are actually criticizing science
itself much like Emperor Palpatine he
went on Stephen Colbert's show and uh he
says that Ivermectin doesn't work
although the CDC actually does say it
does work but some of the the sort of
the um confusion that came out of the
last few years I think I've asked you
about this but I want to check in more
time did Ivermectin do anything no okay
humans do take it but not for this
purpose right it does not help with
covet and it could be dangerous okay
hydroxychloroquine did it do anything no
no so people who hoarded that no no
reason to have done that okay just just
checking just you got it for a friend
got it okay
okay so the CDC does actually say that
Ivermectin helps with covid and there's
all sorts of interesting studies on uh
hcq so let's just put that aside for
just a second and now I want to link
this back to my conversation with Bill
Maher because we actually started
talking about some of the late night
comics and how everything has become so
hyper partisan and that you know in
effect there's a reason that Gutfeld is
crushing it as number one in late night
it's not only because gutfeld's a good
dude and he's funny and the show is
interesting and it's free form and all
that stuff but it's also because these
other guys Colbert Kimmel Etc they've
just become as I put it part of the
machine and that machine loves fauci and
that machine loves control and all of
those things
but isn't that crazy that you're right
that all the all the comics that were
supposed to put everybody to bed or
whatever it is they all went bananas
left I mean these guys are terrible like
Kimmel to me is just [ __ ] you may be
friends with him I know a lot of people
yeah like he's Colbert
yeah like those guys to me they're just
the worst sort of partisan nonsense you
want everybody but the good part of that
is we don't hide it like he doesn't like
me and I don't like him and we don't
deny it and we don't like it no but he's
nothing yeah he's nothing he's very
successful no no but he's just giving
the machine what it wants all the time
you giving you for my differences I
totally respect you as well said yeah
giving the machine What It Wants I wish
I had thought of that phraseology that's
exactly right okay so giving the machine
what it wants that's what Colbert does
he brings out he trots out all of the
Democrats he trots out all the CDC
people all of them and he tells you how
great they are and how wonderful they
are he's a he's a partisan and a hack
working at a mainstream Network that's
just what it is I was really happy in
that moment that that bill got it right
bill again I have some differences with
the guy he's not giving the machine what
it wants if you want to if Bill was
giving the machine what it wants he
would never be criticizing the walksters
he would never be asking questions about
vaccines even if you think he did it too
late even if you think he's not critical
enough of trump all of those things uh
he's too critical of trump etc etc but
then to prove the point of uh the
machine and Colbert and fauci uh well
here's Colbert and fauci uh I'll just
watch this are you worried at all about
the new booster no no no are you are you
worried you're not worried that the the
5G chip that it puts in you is going to
interfere with the 3G chip from the last
one Bill Gates and I decided we're going
to take the chips out now we're not
going to oh really oh how used to
needles are you pretty pretty crazy yeah
have you had any Botox because no at 81
you look fantastic you can't tell me
this is natural
let me know if you need some condoms
I'll ask for you okay oh spooky season
is coming up what scares you the most
thousand kids coming to my door
breathing on me
okay so look there's nothing funny about
that obviously it's canned laughter for
him even to say at the end and I get
he's trying to be funny and he's just
not funny and he's on a non-comedy show
that what really makes him nervous is
kids laugh kids uh breathing on him it's
actually kind of disgusting right it
really is kind of disgusting but he's
vaxxed he just had covet again he's
boosted up the Wazoo he wants all these
kids vaxxed but my my broader point to
bring it to what I was discussing with
Bill is that Colbert is just he's just
part of the machine that there is
nothing honest it will mock and make fun
of everyone who honestly asks questions
or who thinks about things a little bit
differently or dare I mean imagine if
Colbert brought on someone who say
didn't get vaxxed someone who thought
about things for themselves and made
choices for themselves like hey maybe
Dave Rubin
I don't want to change the topic
altogether yeah go ahead I am unvaxxed
you're smoking the same joint yeah it
could take you out at any moment I'm so
worried what was your millionth clue
[Laughter]
uh oh you're unboxed yeah I'm good for
you I would not do it you know what
there were a million reasons that I
wouldn't do it but then when they
started pushing it on people for their
employees the companies for their
employees I have people that work for me
that are in my studio every day just
like you and I remember I don't have a
hundred remember it was OSHA wanted if
you had 100 employees they said you had
to get them backs so I don't have 100
employees but I had guys in myself
enough to ring the bell I have enough to
ring the bell and my guys are in sitting
with me and they're all young in their
20s and I remember thinking I was
looking at them I literally said it on
air I was like wait a minute what
[ __ ] right would I have to tell you
guys to get vaxed and I was like there
is no and I'm very proud that I I'm not
I know a zillion people with all kinds
of problems now
that's right I am unpacked and I did not
force these two fine gentlemen to be
vaccinated either but Colbert would
never want to have that conversation
right he would never want to put someone
who didn't just go for exactly the
spoon-fed nonsense that the corporations
and the pharmaceutical companies and
everything else want you to have and if
you want to see how how pervasive all of
this is uh Dr Simone gold who was one of
the front line doctors right at the very
beginning of kovid who was saying we
need to think about these things
differently and that masks don't make
sense and social distancing is a farce
and we shouldn't be locking people down
and we have to be wary of the vaccines
and all of that stuff she eventually
because she showed up at the Capitol on
January 6th ended up in jail for two or
three months she just got out she put up
this tweet I mean this is just if you
want to see how how incredible it is how
the machine operates wow Pfizer ran paid
vaccine promotion that tells children to
go to a website to view a Marvel comic
book that advertises their their
vaccines this shocking advertisement
targeting minors should be illegal and
yes it is true here is a tweet from
Pfizer they sponsored an Avengers
cartoon when Ultron wreaks Havoc The
Avengers act as the first line of
defense people can help protect
themselves by staying up to date with
their covid-19 vaccinations head on over
to blah blah blah and buy the freaking
comic book so do you see how the machine
despite the fact
that right now our Surgeon General in
Florida is releasing a study showing
that there are heart issues with 18 to
39 year olds the machine Pfizer which
sponsors all of the news shows that
people watch on Sundays and every night
on cable news uh we got a problem here I
think you got it we got a problem here
and it's continuing so now to to back up
a little bit also to what bill and I
were talking about this divide between
Florida and California these are the two
these are the two faces of the nation
let's say and we have to pick which way
we're going to go well Simone gold
continued on Twitter when it came to
California she said California just
became the first state in the nation to
mandate that all children take mRNA
vaccines in order to attend school
Florida on the other hand now recommends
against the MRNA vaccine for males 18 to
39 years old Florida follows the science
California does not so this divide it is
widening and I think actually it's good
that it's dividing if you live in
California right now and you just want
to keep injecting your kids with a bunch
of stuff that you have no idea what it's
doing on top of the fact that the the
virus is 99 Point whatever it is 997
recovery rate for kids and now there's
all of these studies that are starting
to show that there are heart issues and
other side effects if you want to keep
doing that California and you want to
keep voting for people like avenuesome
then I guess stay in California and
we'll see the results of this over the
years and I would say 10 20 years from
now there's going to be a whole bunch of
kids who had been locked down and masked
up and injected with all kinds of stuff
who are going to be not very kind when
they're putting their parents into old
age homes but the point of all of this
really is to show that the people who
are moving on this the people who are
the the insanity party as I say versus
the dissanity party
they are not going to stop they are not
going to stop and we have to figure out
how to build better things and inoculate
ourselves vaccinate ourselves in the
true sense of the vaccine from their bad
ideas Newsome is not going to stop he is
he is injecting children he's forcing
children to be uh injected and now I
have to show you I saw this video this
weekend I almost barfed and I thought
well if I almost barf then I'm going to
cause other people to almost barf here
is
Justin Trudeau that soulless lizard
person from Canada he's in California
right now with the other soulless lizard
person Gavin Newsom and guess what
they're teaming up
to stop climate change hey everyone
I'm in California today with Governor
Newsom uh we're assigning an agreement
to make sure we continue the Deep
partnership we've had on fighting
climate change on protecting our
environment and creating good green jobs
and moving forward in ways that really
matter to people is
Governor Newsom talk about this
partnership
but you don't have to speak the same
language to understand that we're all in
this together divorce is not an option
and so we're here on the issue that
extends I think a global Consciousness
and that's the issue of climate change
and uh you're in a state where we're
experiencing the extremes and so we're
on the leading and cutting edge of not
only dealing with the realities of it
but also the opportunities and that's
why it's so wonderful to have you down
here prime minister to focus on those
Partnerships and the opportunity to
advance together we only Build a Better
World if we're doing it together and
Gathering like-minded Partners like
California and Governor Newsom is the
way that we make this better future a
reality for everyone
I honestly cannot imagine two more vapid
dishonest as I said soulless lizard
people also when Gavin Newsom said
divorce is not an option I feel like he
said that to his wife like three
thousand times she's probably like I
can't take this divorce is not an option
if you think that these two buffoons who
have only wrecked havoc on their states
and their countries can do anything when
it's related to climate change then I
got a bridge to sell you everything that
Gavin Newsom touches he destroys
everything that Justin Trudeau touches
he destroys they both are all about
censoring their opposition and people
who disagree with them and now they'll
just move they'll move from everything
that they did related to covet and
silencing people they will move to
silencing people and censoring people if
it has anything to do with their climate
agenda and by the way they know that
they can't the truth is they know I
don't think they are so uh stupid to
believe that they can do anything when
it comes to climate change this is all
about them attaining more state power
making sure that you peons do whatever
they want they are they are just like
Colbert they give the machine whatever
it wants and right now the big thing
with the machine you can feel it gaining
momentum right now the big thing is
covet has kind of gone away is now this
is all about climate so Michael
schellenberger and you guys know Michael
schellenberger I've had him on the show
a couple times he also ran against Gavin
Newsom for governor in California
unfortunately did not go well but he's
been studying climate change for many
many years he had a tweet about what's
going on with this conversation around
climate change and hurricanes and much
more
the New York Times says climate change
is quote making storms like hurricane
Ian more destructive end quote but
that's false there have been 15 category
four or stronger landfalling hurricanes
in Florida since 1919 10 occurred before
1960
and just five cents according to U.S
government agency NOAA Now what's great
about this is that this is what the New
York Times does with everything this is
what remember remember our buddy Don
Lemon a week ago when he was uh talking
to a uh climate scientist and he said
well when I was younger storms weren't
as strong so this must be climate change
and the guy was like uh don you're an
idiot this is what they do with
everything they don't care about stats
they don't care how many hurricanes used
to hit that were strong or anything they
want to do everything for political
agenda gain more power over the people
take more of the people's money take
more of the people's freedom that is
what it is that is whether it's Colbert
whether it is the New York Times as an
institution whether it is Newsom and the
other one you got it given the machine
what it wants uh speaking of giving the
machine what it wants uh there is the
crazy racist woman Joy Reid over on
MSNBC and she has been very very upset
with Ron to say this because he's
telling the truth about the media's
intentions when it comes to people who
push back on the nonsense
the President also met with Florida
leaders including Republican Governor
Ron DeSantis the two played nice shaking
hands and exchanging thank yous it comes
after DeSantis just yesterday had this
to say about hurricane Ian
quite frankly you know you have National
regime media that they wanted to see
Tampa because they thought that that'd
be worse for Florida that's how these
people think I mean they don't care
about the people of this state they
don't care about the people this
community they want to use storms and
destruction from storms as a way to
advance their agenda National regime
media those comments came those comments
just so happened to come the same day
DeSantis brought actual relief efforts
to a halt
in Fort Myers so he could do a photo op
wearing campaign gear and a pair of
mysteriously squeaky clean knee-high
white boots
those boots sparked a lot of Joy on the
socials with all the memes
okay so that's actually not true they
didn't stop anything DeSantis has been
out on the road and Casey DeSantis
endlessly non-stop since the hurricane
has hit by the way in three days three
days since hurricane Ian hit Florida
rebuilt the road to Pine Island which is
absolutely extraordinary and DeSantis is
already talking about building back the
causeway to Sanibel I have just no doubt
that we will do it way faster way faster
than any other state or if the federal
government got involved or anything else
here's the unedited clip that Joy Reid
is going after DeSantis for I was going
to say everyone that I've talked to on
the ground when we're delivering
supplies they're saying I was watching
the media they told us Tampa yeah that's
why I didn't leave I know people
personally on the island is there gonna
be any accountability in the media well
look I mean I think I think part of it
quite frankly you know you have National
regime media that they wanted to see
Tampa because they thought that that'd
be worse for Florida that's how these
people think I mean they're they're that
they don't care about the people of this
state they don't care about the people
this community they want to use storms
and destruction from storms as a way to
advance their agenda and they don't care
what destruction's in their wake they
don't care about the lives here if they
can use it to pursue their political
agenda they will do it and so I think
there was a lot of build up about that
and look we were obviously concerned
about Tampa too but I think there was so
much emphasis on it that I do think
people said you know even and then it
was supposed to go in as a cat too
actually in the Tampa I think people
said well I'm 125 miles away from here
maybe I'm better off hunkering down I
absolutely think that impacted decision
making okay so the point of all of this
is that the guy is out there
fighting for his State we are
functioning at an incredibly high level
electricity has been brought back to
most areas supplies are there there's no
looting notice you haven't seen any
videos of looting if this happened in
virtually any other state the disaster
that happened here the abject disaster
there would be looting there would be
crime all of those things there has been
Law and Order there have been people
chipping in it it has been absolutely
extraordinary what's going on here but
what the machine again this comes back
to the machine the corporate machine and
and the people who just suck up to it
whether it is Don Lemon whether it is
Joy Reed or of course whether it is the
brilliant women of the view here is
Sunny Hostin and sunny is as I've
pointed out many times I think she's
probably the worst person on television
maybe it's Joy Reid but Sunny probably
is it uh and you can see she's making
the move here I wanna I wanna tease it a
little bit because I I keep telling you
guys the move that they are going to
make on DeSantis is DeSantis is Trump
but worse so they're going to say Trump
was Hitler but this is Hitler on
steroids because Trump at least was
disorganized and confused and you know
he was a television starting all that
but DeSantis is smart and organized so
he's going to be double Hitler here's
Sunny hosta what I did admire about
about
um DeSantis is that he finally talked
about climate change right he like sort
of finally said wow this is a climate
change issue and I think what's always
disappointed me about DeSantis is he's a
very different political candidate than
let's say a president Trump I firmly
believe that President Trump is just not
the the smartest guy I really I don't I
think he's educated but I just don't
think he's that smart and
um and I think he's a racist and I think
he's a homophobe and he's a just a
person who was raised that way when you
look at DeSantis he graduated from Yale
University he went to Harvard Law School
he earned a commission in the U.S Navy
as a jack officer he was a federal
prosecutor who did what I did was where
he targeted and convicted child
Predators he still serves in the United
United States Reserve so what that tells
me is he's brilliant and the cruelty is
the point when he's sending immigrants
all over the place and not taking care
of them and that yeah but I think you've
got to call him as you see him you see
it I mean you can see the move guys
that's why I keep doing this because I
want you to be able to see it so you can
tell your friends that this is exactly
what they're when you hear all these
people well I you know I kind of get it
the worksters are crazy the Democrats
are nuts I just can't vote for Trump and
then overnight they're going to switch
it so that those same exact people will
be saying I can't vote for DeSantis
because he's smart and he's organized
and he knows what he was doing and he
was in the military and all that and of
course everything she said there about
Trump is nonsense I mean she's just just
terrible I don't like you lady uh but
okay what do you do what do I often tell
you you must do you must push Back
Against the Machine however you can do
it in your own life and especially if
you're a politician or a pundit you must
not give the machine What It Wants You
must call out the nonsense so here's a
really nice moment from over the the
weekend Glenn Younkin who is the
governor of Virginia and as you guys
know he was not going to be the governor
of Virginia when polls came out only a
few weeks before he was losing he was
not going to win and then he started
going after the woke stuff and he
started making sure that kids were going
to be protected in school and they
weren't going to pull all this trans
nonsense and all of that and then he
ended up winning well he was on Jake
tapper's show over the weekend and you
can watch how Jake tries to get him I
mean just heavy-handed nonsense and
Glenn Younkin comes back with how about
some of that uh sanity is he playing
because he just released it this week at
Scales back Virginia's wind and solar
energy emphasis instead focuses on
nuclear power economic competition but I
wonder if the events in your first year
as Governor the more intense hurricanes
which scientists say they're more
intense because of climate change the
war in Ukraine and this week's OPEC
decision making the insecurity of where
we get our fuel from uh highlighted
doesn't that suggest that you should be
that we should be leaning into more
green energy not less well to be clear
what I what I've called for is an all of
the above and in fact it's not reducing
an emphasis on Renewables wind and solar
it's correcting an error that was made
in the previous administration's energy
plan which was to exclude everything
else and so we need to yes move forward
with wind and solar we need to move
forward with carbon capture and natural
gas we need to move forward with nuclear
and one of the things that I believe is
that we have a great opportunity in
Virginia to lead the nation in the
development of small modular reactors in
nuclear in order to provide base load
power that's clean and reliable and
affordable and this is why Common Sense
has to come back into this equation
which is we we can't evacuate one of our
strengths which is the fact that we
innovate in America we can in fact find
a way that natural gas can continue to
be a huge part of our overall power
stack we can innovate across nuclear and
we can Embrace Renewables like wind and
solar but we're going to have to adopt
all of them in order to get where we
want to be which is reliable affordable
and a clean power stack
ain't it great when people who know what
they're talking about and have thought
the issues through actually State their
case clearly sure we can do some of the
green stuff we can do some wind stuff we
can do some water stuff we can do some
nuclear stuff there's other things that
we have to do we can't ignore fossil
fuels let's do these things in tandem
Jake who unfortunately you know he's a
Democrat he's just a Democrat act that
is pretending to be a journalist so he
mentions all this and shouldn't we be
green it doesn't mean any shouldn't we
be green it would be nice a weird Kermit
the Frog let's be green and then Junkin
just comes in and says uh well actually
uh there's a lot of ways to skin a cat
and we're not going to destroy the
economy in the name of you know the
green new deal so I just thought that
was a really nice moment and I think
what's going to happen is more and more
people are going to realize that they
will have a Breaking Point with all of
this and perhaps the ultimate
realization of that will be hopefully a
giant red wave when it comes to the
midterms we we shall see but I asked
Bill Maher about just that that is there
something that could happen that would
get a guy like him despite having a good
life in Los Angeles and making money and
having parties and friends and all of
those things is there a way that you
know a guy like him would just say you
know what I can't take Cali anymore and
DeSantis is pretty good and Florida's
pretty spectacular
if California yeah says I have to take
shots
and DeSantis says I don't
hello Florida
that's what I'll say about DeSantis
he's a good dude he's a good dude
he really is and he doesn't care whether
you smoke weed and he doesn't care who
you marry just he doesn't but to sound
like the uh
voiceover and a movie that's coming out
soon
[ __ ] just got real
but like for me personally really [ __ ]
just got real with that yeah and that's
that's in my mind I left this place
because of it and I don't want to leave
the leave this place that it would be
very hard I'm 66 years old I know I look
40. look amazing the hair seems thicker
than it was years a couple years I don't
know what your dinner but he was not
easy but it's not easy for anyone right
so everyone gets to their breaking point
now I know a lot of you that have seen
the light a long time ago and maybe
you're more conservative leading or you
already live in Florida you're like ah
but I wouldn't even want someone like
him coming here or it's like do we have
to do all the Dirty Work do we always
have to do everything right while you
know the Liberals and the lefties
destroy everything and then only at the
last moment when it hits them in the
head because the government's trying to
forcibly inject them with something we
have to save them and I get that there's
a a challenge there and I will continue
to have that conversation with Bill if
you watch again it's a little bit over
two hours I hope you'll watch the whole
thing because you'll see the first 20
minutes we kind of have to do this dance
and it's like we're sort of really
really feeling each other out but then
around about a half hour in for the next
hour and a half we are we are fully in
the flow and it's in and out of politics
and all of our differences and all that
but again it's not driven purely by
politics you're not going to believe
this guys but not everything is
political but the point is everyone has
a Breaking Point and if Justin Trudeau
and Gavin Newsom are going to keep
spitting in the face of science as well
as Anthony fauci and Stephen Colbert and
then there will be Haven there will be
safe havens where science will be truly
looked at and analyzed properly and not
owned by any one person and and more
importantly than any of that regardless
of what the science says that people
will be allowed to make decisions for
themselves and they're for their
children well then let's have that
battle that is the battle that perhaps
the country has to have and maybe more
broadly it's the battle that America has
to have and all of us have to figure out
how to have some of these difficult
conversations uh before we just
completely Splinter off and and maybe
that is inevitable either way uh but I
think there's a chance and and that's
why I framed Today's Show around uh the
podcast with Bill I'm sure we'll be
talking about it more throughout the
week and and all that good stuff stick
around for a cold close in just a moment
it's me Monday over at
reubenreport.locals.com I posted this
one this morning I really like sports in
the color blue let's schedule the
surgery
I'll probably be banned from YouTube for
putting that one up but I won't be
banned on local so you can always find
me there a couple comments from the
locals Community weekly cigar says funny
that media back then didn't expose
fraudi now he needs to be exposed once
the Republicans take the Senate and
House he will be investigated look it's
going to happen
assuming the Republicans take the house
which that one seems very obvious the
Senate's a little bit closer but I think
Blake Masters will win in Arizona I
think Oz will win in Pennsylvania I
think it's going to happen who the hell
knows right but should there be
investigations into these people and the
answer simply is yes these people need
to be investigated fauci has lied you
know that fauci is worth five million
dollars more in the last two years since
covid and that's something he's the
highest paid person in the federal
government he has a lifetime pension of
over four hundred thousand dollars if
I'm not mistaken and he made another
five million throughout this and if he
made five million and we know about that
then it's got to be a lot more through
all sorts of other proxies and family
members and all kinds of stuff so yeah
the the investigations probably have to
happen Rich says I love when Dave does
his Trudeau impersonation now I'm Justin
Trudeau I have nice thoughts and the
climate's coming to get you and I'm
going to freeze your bank account if you
say anything bad about me I'm Justin
Trudeau and I'm Gavin Newsom I have I
sound evil
EK says uh if they say that hurricanes
and other storms are getting stronger
enough times they won't need the
evidence to back it up people will just
accept it as the truth what a great
comment and and that's why they censor
they just say it over and over and over
again it's sort of why I played you that
that Jake Tapper clip right there
because on its face it doesn't seem like
what Jake is doing is so bad but his
conclusion of oh there's some problems
with the environment so shouldn't we be
more great I almost did my Trudeau there
so that's generally be more green
and it's like no man you're you're
subtly putting it in because you have
for so long accepted all of the
narrative accepted all of the [ __ ]
related to climate science and covet and
all of these things that you just have
to keep going I also think that's one of
the reasons that they're so interested
in injecting all of the kids because
think about it if you're if you're an
adult and you're roughly a free thinker
and you're a good parent you're a decent
human being doesn't matter what
political allegiance you have but if
they get you to inject your kid with
something
man you have just jumped you have just
taken a leap not a leap of faith well
it's a leap of faith that the thing
works or it's not going to give them all
sorts of side effects but you have
jumped into the unknown right you don't
know what it's going to do they forced
you to do it maybe you didn't want to do
it but now you have to sort of be all in
on that you have to be all in on it
because otherwise you were the one who
decided to inject your kid with
something that you don't even know what
it is or whether it was necessary in the
first place so you're kind of you better
be all in with them because what are you
gonna what are you gonna say you're
gonna look in the mirror and be like boy
I I really I really screwed up maybe I
shouldn't have ejected my kid with that
thing
by the way wasn't that a nice moment
when I told Mar that I'm unvaxxed and
his his initial reaction was what do you
say well good for you well good for you
good for you and I don't regret it at
all I'm actually very proud that I
fought the machine and did what I
thought was right for myself and my
family as you should too all right
ladies and gentlemen I think this is a
fine Monday show I'm sure I have to go
change a diaper or feed somebody or
something like that as always subscribe
at rumble.com reubenreport and
reubenreport.locals.com my full
interview with Dennis Prager I just
adored Dennis and if you want some
wisdom when I think of Dennis Prager I
think of two things with Dennis I think
if Joy he's one of the happiest
smileiest joyous guys I know sometimes
maybe that doesn't come across when he's
doing his radio show and talking
politics but as a person just an
absolute true pleasure but wisdom really
is the word and finally I saw this one
going viral this morning on Twitter this
is a spectacular Joe Biden song to take
you home see you tomorrow everybody
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
like to be able to
anyway
I'm my mind's going blank though I can't
remember
[Music]
I don't know what the hell he's talking
about doing here
I don't think is
the idea
[Music]
the political coverage
I want to thank and recognize Dr John
John
[Music]
[Music]
no idea no idea no idea
foreign